hi everybody welcome back to our astro
bookshelf
hangout that we do on most thursdays
here on deep astronomy my name is tony
darnell
i run this place and today we are
talking with dr brian keating as we
generally do about his
what his goings on are on his channel uh
he gives us previews of some really
great interviews that he has in
particular this one we're going to be
talking about his interview he had with
dr
sean m carroll who is a one of my
personal heroes and i
i loved watching his interview and it
was really uh very interesting i would
i would invite you because the purpose
of these hangouts is to let you guys my
audience know
about what's going on on his channel
because there's a lot of overlap there
and i want to i want to highlight what
he's doing there so by all means
click on the link downstairs uh
in the uh description box to watch the
full interview but do it after
we're done because uh you want to talk
you want to hear what we have to say
first and we'll give you a nice
and we'll give you a nice um uh
introduction and
and everything to get you set up and
ready to go for that for that uh
discussion so
let me before i bring brian up i got a
couple of announcements to make uh
here on the deep astronomy world
headquarters
if you have and i don't know why you
would but if you do have
an alexa dot or an alexa
smart speaker thingy in your house
then space fan news is available to you
now posted weekly i have a
what do they call that a flash briefing
that i'm posting every monday
of space fan news space headlines
and uh you could tune it in by just
saying hey alexa
what's my flash briefing and then you'll
you get to search somehow auditorially
and pick space fan news but the easiest
way to do it that i found is just get on
the alexa
app and make do a search for space fan
news and add it to your flash briefing
and it will come up every time you say
hey man not hey man but you guys say hey
alexa
you know do this now i know that's weird
coming from me that i'm on
alexa right now any space fan news is
because i have a massive distrust of
these things
anything with a microphone in my house
however i got one
i don't know how i got it i think
somebody gave it to us and we set it up
and the sound was actually pretty good i
play spotify on mine a lot
and i found out about these things and i
wanted to find out how to do it the
computer geek in me made me want to
figure it out so
every week i'll be posting something on
alexa for you
to watch um or to listen to okay
um so let me go ahead and bring up my
co-host hort hey brian
you're on are you there what are you
doing i am
typing in uh that i have had an alexa
ring i bought one of those alexa alexa
loops i think they were called
oh yeah i did a review of it an unboxing
on my channel
over the summer and i got a lot of hate
mail for that but uh but that's okay
uh people were saying because i put it
out of security flaw
in it that it can basically read you
know someone can just find it and pick
it up and start
uh you know hearing your email finding
out what kind of
pills you're buying on amazon what kind
of uh products you might not
want people to know about so can tell
them your whole shopping list
and so i did a review uh that it is not
ready for
prime time so look for that in uh my
videos over the summer but it's a
serious security flaw
in my opinion so yes well right now but
but i do have a lot of
uh alexis alexa play uh what was it
called
this one's a dot um it's like the
cheapest thing you can get
uh but what's the name of your show or
the uh oh it's called space fan news uh
space fan news headlines
and it's really cool because i try to be
like npr and i say
from deepastronomy.com here is space fan
news
i'm tony darnell alexa play space fan
news
oh come on alexa play space
fan news
you got to do it at the flash briefing
to intervene and the voting in two swing
states ah say you got npr
alexa stop want to extend the time alexa
stop
for the love of zeus please stop
running my life i mean i basically
bought everything i bought uh
the green screen behind me my computer
monitor stand etc etc so they already
know
what colored pills i'm buying yeah yeah
and i'm sure you can order all kinds of
stuff from your account too when
somebody gets your thing
anyway i did it because i wanted to know
how hard it was to do
and it's really not that bad you set up
an xml file that's public you set up a
you record an mp3 file that's also
public and
i put mine on an s3 bucket and i'm i'm
done you know and i just filled out the
thing
and so um you know that's how i did it i
might do a couple skills i might do one
that's like
what's up tonight you know and then have
it uh
say what the bright things are up
tonight like if you look in the south
uh in the south west or something
mars is the bright red dot there's
another bright dot that's jupiter
something very general that most people
would want not something in depth like
well m31 is way over here and if you
have a six-inch telescope it's going to
look like this
all about the smudges it's all about the
dots and smudges
that's right so i don't know i might do
that if this is yeah that's
cool yeah so anyway i'm doing that um
you can get into the impossible podcast
by the way you can listen to
the latest episode of the into the
impossible podcast so you do okay so you
i wonder if i can get space fan or space
junk podcast on yeah you can i think
it probably automatically gets uploaded
if you're on stitcher or whatever you
know
i am on stitcher so are these things
should go up
oh okay cool well i'll have to test that
out then see see if we can get it on
alexa
i don't know how many people watching
this have this smart
crap they call it smart speakers and all
this i personally
um it's scary to me i don't like
microphones directly linked to jeff
bezos in my house
but you know the only place i have it
besides behind me here in the studio is
in my bathroom
and i figure you know if they want to
hear and analyze
whatever that's brave whatever big bangs
and dark matter is being produced
oh man that's a little tmi man wow
you're broadcasting that dude
hey jeff take this man guess what i had
for lunch today
oh no no i don't use the camera turn off
the camera
oh that's crazy all right so brian get
into the subject here
you talked with my one of people i love
to listen to on his mindscape podcast dr
sean carroll um and he's talking about
all kinds of weird stuff in this
in this podcast your your interview so
for those of you who are checking in for
the first time why don't you give an
introduce
what you're doing over on your neck of
the woods and
what you talked to sean about and yeah
did you by any chance have any clips
this time or are we just going to talk
about it
um if you want to go to the video
uh while i'm talking you could probably
mute it and show it right
um just from my youtube channel i could
maybe try that yeah if you want a screen
share i'll talk about it
so here's what happened so in 1997
i was a graduate student at uh brown
university and one day
across the uh early version of the new
york times
uh web page i saw the universe is all
screwed up
and here's evidence for uh for the
twisted universe so to speak
and i was really quite amused and
shocked and also excited because
the claim was that astronomers had
detected
a directionality in space which sounds
like okay there's a lot of directions in
space there's the direction of the sun
the galactic center the black hole
in sagittarius a star there's all sorts
of things that seem to
prefer certain reference frames in the
universe
including as i had studied for a long
time the cmb
dipole which reflects the fact that the
earth is a planet riding on a
running in a solar system around a
galaxy which is moving with respect to
uh the rest frame of the cosmic
microwave background photons
and that you might think would define an
axis in the universe
it turns out it doesn't necessarily do
so in the way that would violate
one of the most cherished traditions in
all of physics laws some say
and that's called lorentz invariance
violation
liv for short and crime in some states
that's right you have to obey the law as
einstein would say
it's one of the underpinnings of uh
of all of uh modern physics
so actually if you go to my blog if you
go to briankeating.com right now i'll
walk people through tony how to get the
slides that shawn and i reviewed
in our podcast together so if you go to
briankeeding.com
click on blog you will be first of all
you should all subscribe to my
newsletter because i have
a lot of fun things coming up including
my new book which i'll be talking about
uh in in future episodes with with tony
no doubt i'm going to
uh whoa look at this thing
sign up for the twisted universe uh
newsletter
and i will uh i have to make me bigger
because they're looking at some
tiny version of me okay there we go
great all right so click up to where it
says blog
oh okay and you click on that i go down
contact brian go to sean carroll the
yellow lettering there you should be
able to click on that
um right there yeah and then scroll down
and that should be number seven i think
right there stop go back up
it should say download a pdf so click on
that tony
and download uh for free sean carroll
there you go so everyone go through this
please do sign up for my newsletter
uh and you should be able to open this
or save it or what have you
and what was announced back in 1997 uh
really startled me and it also must have
sent a thrill
up sean carroll's leg because sean had
predicted an effect
back in 1990 when he was a beginning
graduate student at harvard university
with george field and roman jakiev an
effect
uh that would lead to the very same
observations that were made
and if you stop there if you go right
there so this is what precipitated the
conversation this week this past week
there was a claim produced on physics
review letters physical review letters
which is
the most uh prestigious highest impact
pure physics journal in the world
nature has higher impact but but anyway
physical review letters is for the most
urgent
the most important news items newsworthy
not news but actual research articles so
there was a
abstract printed they didn't print the
whole paper the paper is not available
on the archive
but it said that there was a extraction
of cosmic birefringence from planck 2018
data
and they show there this beta which is a
parameter that shows how much the
universe is twisted in a certain sense
that i can discuss
and they said they detected it with a
significance that exceeded
2.2.4 sigma
which corresponds as tony knows to a
confidence
of 99.2 percent in other words
uh there's only 1.8 percent chance
statistically speaking
formally of this arising by chance
now i don't know about you but i'd enter
a lot of lotteries especially one that
would pay out
with a golden medallion uh bequeathed in
scotland uh stockholm
uh if i'd enter a lot of lotteries that
gave me a 99
uh chance of winning uh so this was
quite startling and if confirmed and as
the authors say
uh there still needs to be research done
but uh but sean's theory would somehow
be ratified so my prediction is if
this were confirmed that sean would
probably win the nobel prize for coming
up with the theory behind
it and so if you go down to the next
slide tony
uh you'll see that this paper came out
on galileo's birthday in 1990 and the
426th birthday
of galileo and it was fitting that that
happens because
lorentz violation is sort of a special
case
of what's called galilean relativity
which is that the laws of physics don't
depend
on your reference frame and what lorentz
violation means is that they would
depend on your reference
frame there would be some reference
frames are more special than others
and what sean showed in the subsequent
slide
is that you could actually change
maxwell's equation there's good old
james clerk
and you could modify the electromagnetic
lagrangian that
script l there which is that really
that's the rosetta stone
or as uh sean sean carroll as eric
weinstein
uh often describes it you know it's kind
of like the the force field the
governing entity the the rosetta stone
of all
physics is encoded in what's called the
lorentz uh lagrangian
and by adding this term it's possible a
special term called the chern
simons term which has a connection to my
uh patron
my friend jim simons that uh the
result would be that physics would
acquire a lorentz violating
or perhaps parody violating and lorenz
violating
uh phenomena and that's what happened
okay so let's let's just review what you
just said because i'm a little bit lost
the the you started by saying the
universe does not have a preferred
direction that's lorenz's i didn't say
that lorenzo
well okay but that was that was the
thing now first of all
i don't know what you mean by a
direction do you mean because we live in
a three-dimensional space plus time
we have x y and z coordinates with a
direction in time what do we mean by a
direction
does the universe always look in a
certain area that just doesn't first of
all make sense to me that statement
yeah so it doesn't make sense because
it's totally out of
uh context with your normal experience
in other words if you drop a ball
and look at it and the earth's
gravitational field it looks the same as
if you
observe that same ball after bouncing
off the light bouncing off a mirror
in other words it obeys certain symmetry
laws such that if you do
a test of the force of gravity inside
your laboratory
and then you move to uh from florida to
california you should get the same
results
in all conservation of momentum
shouldn't depend on where you do the
experiment
it shouldn't depend on what reference
frame you're in and what this is saying
if this were true is that it would you'd
get a different answer if you did it in
a laboratory in florida versus a
laboratory in california
it would depend on where you are in the
universe so imagine
if there is found to be a universal
electric field imagine that there's a
constant electrophore electric field and
it points from the constellation
andromeda
to the constellation delphius well
that would have a certain types of
behaviors you'd get different behaviors
uh of particles of forces of fields
depending on
how your experiment was oriented with
respect to that electric field
okay and so to violate lorenz
one has to have a preferred direction
upon which your results of an experiment
depend
yes it could be a preferred direction or
a preferred position
so you could in the case i just gave it
gave a
dependence on you know which state we're
in and uh but it could also be which
direction you're looking in so there's
three spatial coordinates
there's three um there's three angles
that specify
where something takes place or two
angles uh specify it on the two sphere
and then there's a dimension of time
which could say you could also violate
this and that could be time dependent
as is sort of related to the claim
that's being made in this paper
okay so using your gravity analogy in
florida versus california
if this were being violated there were a
preferred direction to gravity
in the universe then if i drop a ball in
florida it will fall at a certain rate
in a certain with certain vectors that
are consistent with my being in florida
however
i moved to california and do that
experiment
something is different because of the
fact that i'm in florida one of maybe
their speed is different maybe the
x direction is a little off or something
like that am i am i visualizing this
right
yes that's exactly right you'd be able
to tell where you are in the universe
that's that's the thing that's the key
is that
you would have something right okay so i
would know that i'm in california based
on how that ball fell
exactly uh because there's a
characteristic behavior of gravity at
this location
exactly um okay and that's what you mean
by reference frame
it could also apply to my velocity
somewhere as well
at different speeds or doing this in an
airplane rotation
okay wow and so sean predicted
that the universe
sean sean explored the consequences of a
universe
if this effect were present
okay and he actually tested it and set
limits on the maximum
amount of lorentz violation and parity
violation
that could take place if the universe
had this additional component
that uh that we don't believe
well we know for certain isn't present
in the so-called
standard model of of physics which is
gravity and quantum mechanics
particle physics etc and so if
this were if it did have a preferred
direction the universe
then it would take it would we would be
able to notice it
in this um what would you call it the
some kind of polarization yeah so in
this case if you're going down
in the next slide uh next slide after
that
this kind of sets the stage so if we
stop here now you and i have been
talking
about theories of everything ever since
we were born
but for those that might not know we've
done a bunch of specials and theories of
everything with
some physicists that have their own
theories of everything including
including eric weinstein and uh and uh
and folks like max tag mark we did that
over the summer
and i'm even gonna have a second
conversation with sir roger penrose he
just agreed
it's funny i i sent him congratulations
the day he won the nobel prize and
yesterday he answered me
thank you i said yeah i didn't expect to
hear from you but now that i've got you
uh do you mind coming on the into the
impossible podcast for a live stream
with my audience to take questions and
answers in the next couple weeks and he
said absolutely so look forward to that
please subscribe
to my channel everybody dr brian keating
and they download the into the
impossible podcast as well
so anyway so here's a slide from my
friend matt muse up at
um cal state uh san luis obispo
and he's showing kind of the way that
physicists think about things these
blocks that my kids like to put together
and break apart
the idea is that if there is a theory of
everything it's supported by these three
pillars
namely that uh gravity is a
manifestation of curved space time
the rent symmetry is sort of the uh the
conjecture that and
laws of physics don't depend on position
rotation etc velocity
they can depend on acceleration because
that now impacts curve space time but
we'll leave that alone
and then quantum mechanics the law
schrodinger's equation dirac equation
those all support the standard model of
particle physics on the left
and support general relativities uh that
the two of those together
and then on top of that comes um further
downstream comes electromagnetism
chemistry astrophysics newtonian gravity
etc
so next slide uh please tony
i'm going to call you new tony newtonian
tony
new tony now if you have a slight
breakdown in the exact symmetry of
lorenz
uh invariance then you might see effects
downstream from that manifest in
electromagnetism
you know perhaps atoms would behave
differently if there's some constant
electromagnetic field in the universe
pointing in some direction then you'd
get different results depending on how
your laboratory is
uh is conveyed with respect to that so
the next slide
uh is a slide uh we can skip over
here's the math i'm gonna give tony's
give your audience a couple of seconds
just to
just to verify that equation is right so
yep okay yeah it looks right uh
the j square j phi term yeah i'm not i
think uh i don't know man this this term
here
from here i got a problem with that one
all right well we'll
work on that so now going down to how
you would test it
uh the next slide shows jim simons uh
who is the patron of the
simon's observatory the simon's array
and uh
and many other things in in the world of
pure
basic science and what sean did with his
colleagues in 1990 is add a term to the
lagrangian it's not super important
the key thing is that he added a
specific direction in space
and he added that as a as a as a four
vector as a vector with time and spatial
components
so that there was a direction pointing
in space that was
different than every other direction and
the reason we don't
see any effects of that is that we don't
have photons that have been traveling
far enough for this effect to accrue
to observational levels in other words
we can rule this out on earth we don't
see
uh the polarization of of photons of a
laser say say you polarize a laser beam
and shoot it down a kilometer to another
laser detector
we don't see that rotating unless we put
magnetic material in
and a magnetic field that's called
faraday rotation but
but instead we don't see this in the lab
but maybe
it's just such a small effect it takes
cosmological distances
traversed by photons to accumulate
enough of a rotation
to be detectable so in fact this is
the third or fourth time in history it's
been detected the next slide shows
a claim made about my experiment bicep 1
data
that they detected at greater than 3
sigma this rotation angle which the
authors of the current paper in prl call
beta i don't know why we can't get our
language together i call it alpha they
call it beta
some people call it psi it's not
important it means that
photons will change their orientation as
they come to the observer
they will rotate their plane of
polarization all in the same sense
and that sort of is singling out the
time direction uh
as different from the other the way that
it would depend on the universe that
doesn't break this type of
symmetry so this is adding a type of uh
scalar field to the electromagnetic
lagrangian
that also produces this effect so they
show the same kind of additional
term into electromagnetism now i said
this is the third time it's been
detected currently or evidence for it
i should say that the current authors
just say evidence for or perhaps they
say extracting it from
but they don't go so far as to say that
even with 99 plus percent
confidence that they've detected it so
next slide tony well hang on so in order
to see this
polarization uh shift that you're
talking about
you have to you have to photons have to
be traveling
on the scale of the universe yes uh or
you know at least at the scale of
galaxies
far away radio galaxies that's right so
some of them may be z
megaparsecs or something
so this would this would be in effect if
the universe has a direction
and violates the rents propositions or
whatever without that math we saw
then then uh this would if it would
manifest itself as a
shift in polarization of photons over
the course of a cosmic
distance time distance scale of the
universe
correct and of the observable universe
and you're and this is called cosmic
birefringence
yes yes and birefringence you better
tell
us what that is what that word is yeah
so birefringence is a property of
certain crystals
in particular quartz or calcite crystals
uh one type is known as icelandic
spar i have some of that in my house
somewhere
running calcite is birefringent calcite
is birefringent quartz a specific
crystal structure of course called z-cut
quartz and we make devices that are
polarization modulators
out of known birefringent material like
quartz sapphire is birefringent
etc which just means that as
as polarized light travels through this
crystal
through this material the plane of
linear polarization can rotate
and it can do so independent of
electromagnetic frequency
and it has no effect on unpolarized
light there are other effects that can
cause depolarization and other effects
we won't get into that
but the basic conjecture is that the
universe
is uh as does not possess this property
in other words the vacuum of space
does not produce this this this property
but effectively
if it did it would mean that that light
of one polarization state
travels slower than the speed of light
and the other would be
that would be a property of space time
itself then yeah the vacuum
waste time would be birefringent yes it
would lead to cosmic biorefunctions
that's right and it would be that it
would be true on earth too
it would just be so small that we can't
detect it because
the amount of rotation depends on how
far the photons have traveled you see
that blue
teal colored line that's hard to see but
it is kind of
twisting over the distance and i could
actually make it thick enough that it
rotates by 90 degrees
um so you can make it uh you can
increase the amount of rotation or
birefringence
two ways one a stronger amount of this
uh
this breaking of of parity symmetry
within the vacuum of electromagnetism
or by having a longer path length but
you can't get a longer path length than
going from
the photons produced after the immediate
effects of the big bang namely the
cosmic microwave background or
cmb photons that's the longest path
length possible
in the universe it's effectively almost
the entirety of the entire universe 45
billion light years
that's right yeah so so the next slide
shows
is this right-handed or left-handed so
it could be
uh it could be either one so you could
have either one so that would break
parity symmetry and that
the laws of nature don't depend if
you're looking at something in the
mirror
uh you know they seem to be symmetric
with respect to that
they're not symmetric with what's called
a charge parity
uh symmetry violation but they are
symmetric with respect to charge parity
and time
reversal symmetry and that that's a
subject for another day maybe another
claim detection we'll talk about that
those are called the discrete symmetries
of space-time that all
theories of physics have to live up to
so in some sense this could be used to
test the existence of a theory of
everything which is why
i'm personally extremely excited about
it okay i don't get that connection but
i guess i don't have to okay
here's the here's the new york times
yeah so if you go back to 1997 you're
back i know you've got stockpiled in
your basement all
issues going back to april of 19th are
you calling me a hoarder man
is that what you're saying i'm not a
reporter you're a prepper you're a
hoarder or whatever i am a prepper but
i'm not a hoarder
so at the bottom uh it says this side up
may apply to the universe after all
so that's kind of a tongue-in-cheek way
of saying that there is a preferred
direction
to space i also pointed out to sean i
like the fact that the
new york times is time translation
invariant because you still see newt
gingrich in the new york times every day
or you know
a couple times a month you still see
bibi netanyahu's also there
uh slobodan milosevic and is on there
anyway so
it's just funny that the more things
change i bet you could find donald trump
in there somewhere
uh certainly joe biden was in there
somewhere well there's an argument that
the times kind of made trump because
they loved him for their for the 80 in
the 80s and 90s
oh yeah they kind of built him yeah so
if you look at this slide now this is
getting into a little bit more of the
details so they're showing these two
different axes
that are perpendicular and depending on
which direction light is traveling
uh from a distant radio galaxy that will
produce
a measurable rotation effect that one
could potentially observe
and therefore the polarization of the
light coming through it yes i
want to keep saying that so that we know
what we're talking about yeah so the
next slide shows some of the data
that uh sean had analyzed for his phd
work in that 1990 paper
and uh it shows just a cartoon of what
these radio galaxies look like there's a
seems to be a preferred
orientation between uh between the radio
polarization properties and the optical
polarized properties
and this just describes a little bit
about if you can measure the spatial
geometry
you could measure the uh you could
measure the angle with respect to
polarization
and what sean showed very soon after
which i thought was
amazing feat of scientific integrity
imagine you've predicted
that there is a just imagine you predict
uh
um tony for a second there's a preferred
direction in space
but no one believes you and no one uh
thinks you're right they think you're
smoking
something special that you can get in
california now
but you you you believe it with all your
heart and then somebody comes out with
data that proves you right
and then uh and then you set about to
prove
them wrong i mean i don't know i i saw
this it is refreshing i mean yeah
i don't think i could do that that's why
he's a hero of mine too
sean sean and i differ on on some things
we we agree on other things
and what's so important is how uh as how
he had the scientific integrity
to look at a signal that could have been
you know
uh touted and was touted as having this
incredible
import and proving his papers
conjectures of seven years earlier
and yet he had the integrity to kind of
show that they had made a simple blunder
with the way that they assigned what's
called the sign convention for
polarization
uh polarization can't distinguish unlike
this pen
this pen has an obvious uh you know
parity difference with the point on one
side and the tail on the other side but
imagine a piece of spaghetti
uh which has no symmetry has perfect
symmetry up and down
you can't tell the difference between a
piece of spaghetti like this or a pieces
in a blink and i'll turn it around this
piece of spaghetti like this this
or this are the same thing to
astronomers and what these guys did the
authors of the paper nodlin and ross
ralston and maudlin
they arbitrarily made up a convention
that basically forced them
to get this distribution uh peaked at 90
degrees as shown here
and it was really done kind of
arbitrarily capriciously
and sean discovered that refuted them in
a series of papers
and then this all went away but it's
funny you know because it goes from
front page of the new york times
to completely forgotten but we haven't
forgotten about it and as i said it was
claimed from the bicep 1 data to be
existent
back in 2009 so that's 11 years ago
and lo and behold 2020 comes along and
to add to the
to the amazing simulation as uh as
people are saying in the chat room
uh we have now seeming to believe that
our most
cherished principles of physics namely
lawrence violation
may be getting destroyed in this very
strange year
so we don't have to talk too much more
about this aspect of it i do want to get
to kind of the
the most important part of it is in my
mind
and what separates these authors from
other ones
is that they have done a very careful
job
of looking at what are called systematic
errors and those are errors in the
instrument
uh errors that can come from sources
that aren't cosmological
and mainly mimic and confuse
observers and they've done a good job at
treating that uh and
uh but it was it was interesting to talk
to sean explaining
you know to the audience also how hard
it is to calibrate
an astronomical instrument
yeah and why that's so important right
and uh yeah so i agree that we should
probably not uh
let we'll let sean do the description of
what he's done
and and on in the interview that you had
with him
but this is amazing stuff and i guess i
wonder
about why was the laurence um
postulation given that way in the first
place what what made them what made
everybody think that there wouldn't
be a preferred direction to the universe
why is that the supposition yeah well so
going back i've been reading a lot of
galileo's
or original books in the dialogue in
particular the dialogue on two world
systems
which i always point out had originally
had a much
a much fancier and more attractive title
that galileo gave to it which was uh
on the flux and reflux of tides in the
earth's
rivers and ferns i don't even know what
a fern is but
but that's what galileo wanted to call
the dialogue on the two world systems
and i think you know that really would
be impossible
not to read uh such a book but actually
the pope essentially forced him to
change it to the dialogue
which is good that he did it because uh
it's a much catchier and much more
um much more intriguing title than flux
and reflux of tides
well so that's interesting i did not
know that the pope had
uh input on he didn't have input on
making the format of the book dialogue i
thought galileo did that when he wrote
it
yeah in the form of a dialogue so that
he could have this buffoon
type person with which to put his
arguments against
that's right and the buffoon was
representing the arguments of the pope
that's right which uh which is but it
was always written as a dialogue i guess
is my
point it wasn't yes okay it wasn't
style and in fact even after galileo was
imprisoned
he wrote one more book with the same
three characters
uh called the discourse on two new
sciences which are really about
mechanics and
and what we call uh statics and uh
material science but i'll get into that
some other time
but getting back to the dialogue galileo
spends an awful lot of time talking
about
uh if you drop a cannonball from the
mast of a ship as the ship is sailing at
high speed it will still land at the
base of the ship's mast
if you have a bunch of butterflies in a
jar and they're floating around
in the jar as a boat is sailing they
don't notice that they're moving
and so the relativity of motion as
galileo first
explicated it is really sacrosanct in
physics
and if it did depend on you know motion
we would have a very strange world in
other words
you got different results you could tell
that you're moving
it would have dramatic implications
that's where the relative and
relativity comes from is that it's
impossible to say who's in motion
uh when two objects are at uh are moving
in inertial frames so it'd be very
difficult to do physics if lorentz
violation
took place on a daily basis i see
because
not only do you have that complication
of the preferred direction or the
birefringence of space-time but you've
also got
the complications of your inertial
reference frame so if you're in
one reference frame and i'm in another
and we're doing the same experiment
we're going to get different results as
a result of the fact that we're in
different reference frames especially
with respect to time
but not but with we then have to also
account for
this birefringent effect in the
space time that we're traveling through
and actually aristotle who is not known
for
doing anything correct in physics but
nevertheless
uh had a lot of interesting conjectures
he his
model of the ptolemaic you know it came
to be called the ptolemaic universe
that had a violation of lorenz and
variance in that
it was assumed that heavier things fell
to their centers
in other words that the earth was the
center of the universe because
it's the most important place in the
universe and everything goes
down towards the earth and as we
perceive it and everything orbits around
the earth
and that's proving that you know we are
the center of the universe he also
thought heavier things fall faster than
lighter things etc and that's a form of
lorentz and variance that we know not to
be true
okay well let me get to a couple
questions here dan wants to know
um are you talking about items falling
in a vacuum
i assume you mean when we were doing
that reference
the thing about florida versus
california yeah it doesn't matter really
it could be in a vacuum so if you take a
proton and you put
it in orbit around the earth and you ask
well what's how fast does it fall
it would fall at the same rate if you
did that test assuming it was just
falling around this orbiting the sun
or something it would fall towards the
sun
but if you uh if you had a charged
magnetic field
throughout the universe it would fall in
a different uh velocity depending on
whether or not it was perpendicular or
parallel to that electromagnetic field
so you could you could you know derive
your orientation
and that would break lorentz uh in
variance it would add a preferred vector
field to the
to the universe that we don't observe to
be the case
all right and soul tube so this means we
can find the center of the universe
slash space
we can send a satellite there at
99.9999999 smith
percent of the speed of light with a
message yo god
are you there why the absent parenthood
in politic
all right let's go to the first part of
that so is this indicate
is this somehow pointing us towards the
center of something
well if it were true then yeah so if it
were true it wouldn't necessarily imply
a sector it could apply a direction and
so if you have multiple directions
let's say you had one you know the
universe doesn't have to have one
direction it could have many different
it could have a tensor it could have
all sorts of different phenomena that
would break symmetry
such that you know crystals would form
differently depending on the orientation
of the axis
um and so effectively it's often said
that while the cosmic microwave
background provides a universal
reference frame
but it what we're saying is not that
there's impossible to have a reference
frame
or even a reference frame i mean my gps
will get me to florida just fine
even though you know the earth is a
gravitational field it's not
technically i'm not technically an
inertial reference frame
and what relativity says is that you can
have a whole bunch
of local reference frames local inertial
reference frames
but there's no global one that connects
all of them together such that all
observers will agree
that so and so is motion at constant
velocity
that's really important actually that is
i mean yes it is
there is no spot upon which everything
is at rest
yes right there there is okay that's
right and so there's no
there's no center of the universe right
if there were you know there would
actually be
as this as this listener is saying there
could be an actual
you know claim that there's so and so is
at the center of the universe because
that's where these
symmetries properties would vanish at
the origin i mean it would be symmetric
only in one special location that
location could consider itself
the center of the universe but of course
we don't think that's true
at least until these results are
confirmed
it's really hard to imagine something
like the big bang
and an expanding universe and not
imagine
because we're it's just so common sense
to us anyway
that there is a center somewhere and and
i get that
that bias i want it to be true too it
just makes visualizing the whole big
bang thing
easier the thing is though it betrays
just what the big bang was the big bang
wasn't
an explosion that happened in a spot and
then it
and then it expanded outward uh it
happened
nowhere and then created from it
an expanse of space-time it created
the the map that we live on the the
three-dimensional space that we live in
and if you go to any spot within that
expanding frame there's no center to it
you you can look in all directions
and you're gonna not find any closer to
an edge
than any other spot and it's don't
feel bad if you can't just visualize it
because
it's very it's very uh non-intuitive i
can't visualize it i'll just say it flat
out so yeah well i think how magical it
is
that we we're talking about things that
occur in four dimensions
we're talking about properties of space
time not just space and not just time
and it's pretty imagine amazing that we
can visualize it at all if you think
about it our eyeballs have retinas
that are essentially two-dimensional
structures right so our retina is a film
on the back of our eyeballs
and from two of those we synthesize
perspective
almost like a three-dimensional but we
don't see inside of something right so
we're not really seeing
the three third dimension and now we're
talking about a fourth dimension
so yes it's extremely complex to
visualize these types of phenomena
and no one should really feel you know
it's said that no one can visualize it
there are ways to think about it i'm
going to be doing a special
four-part uh video series on my channel
when i get the time
on a book called flatland which is
really the best science fiction science
fantasy book that i ever read as
a young kid i started reading it when i
was 12 finished reading it when i was
49.
which is hard to i believe because it's
only 89 pages long
but i got it's a pamphlet i got a little
bogged down
for a couple things happened to me along
the way there but it's a delightful book
i've i've read an illustrated version of
it
and it talks about how a a planar
creature a creature living in two
dimensions named
a square could uh conceptualize the
third dimension
as v as as when he encounters a
mysterious creature
called a sphere who comes into flatland
and also causes a lot of trouble for
this character i won't spoil it but
it's an amazing book and i hope to give
my perspectives on it and also
couple it to these new theories of
geometric physics promulgated by my
friend eric weinstein
good well uh definitely we'll check that
out as well okay couple
get i want to get to some comments
frederick rhodes sounds like
birkeland currents you know i don't
nope i have no idea what those are
someone's asking i think andrew
planet is asking andrew hey yeah are we
talking about
ferns like um like like uh biological no
fern to galileo is a river delta and i
think somebody else said that in the
chat so no a fern galileo meant
some kind of river structure that was
called a fern
right and here's a question from neil
brian could this include or could this
indicate dr
turok's universe plus antiverse concept
maybe the antiverse has the opposite
preferred direction
yeah it's interesting there are works of
physics and i talked to sean about this
how this could be coupled into you know
theories of gravity theories of
everything
and in fact you know the the the theory
of everything
presupposes that there is one unified
law of nature physics
and that we already know that
electricity and magnetism are unified
we know that heat and thermodynamics are
unified
we know that the weak force is unified
with
with the electromagnetic force we
suspect that the strong force is unified
with the uh with the weak force and the
electromagnetic force
and then the supposition is well the
theory of everything should unify
all those forces and gravity and i said
what would be the implication
of of such a unification would it be
manifest
in a type of lorenz symmetry violation
or parody symmetry violation
and we talked about this there are uh
neil turock and
and paul steinhardt and others have
different concepts for the universe the
antiverse
but there's also consequences that could
emerge such as
not only photons being chiral or handed
but also gravitational waves being
chiral or handed
so that a left-handed or vertically
polarized gravitational wave if you like
would travel slower than a horizontally
polarized gravitational wave
so yes these are all things that could
have a bearing on uh on
the time direction asymmetry as well as
as well as directional dependence in the
three spatial dimensions of spacetime
let's see i want to get to a couple more
uh so frederick really wants to get god
in here
the positive and negative pole
directions are controlled
by the governance of direct i don't know
what that means
i don't know either um dallas brown is
saying we're very smart i like that
hang on you're you're getting you're
getting ahead of him oh okay i'm gonna
put that one i'm on my channel i don't
know if you're
oh it's on yours okay i'm putting up
okay i'm putting up the questions on the
thing
so uh andrew planet has another question
does the fact
that this universe has a measurable
lifespan
since the big bang imply a trajectory
see that's what i mean right you you
start going there with
with this big bang happening and then
there's an expanding universe the thing
is
the big bang happened in nothing right
there was nothing
upon which it happened so there's no
like direction in nothing
so it's really it's tough man but anyway
what do you say to andrew
so what's the exact question tony sorry
what does this fact can you see what i'm
putting up on the um
screen i
trajectory so trajectory has this
connotation of of direction and space
i don't think that's uh effectively you
know a precise
question in that the universe isn't
moving through something if it's all
there is
now if there happens to be a multiverse
and there's other you know there are
other
uh phenomena there are other things in
the in the universe than we can see
then yes it could be uh you know that we
are moving with respect to another
universe
in the time domain but in a larger
spatial context called the multiverse
all right this has got andrew's this has
got andrew's curiosity up so he's got
another one
uh does the fact that this universe has
a certain specific
age mean that it is relatively finite
but just immensely big
um it could be immensely big and it does
have a finite age we think
but that doesn't mean it had a single
big bang that it was created in a
singular
universe it could be as turok and others
suspect it could be a type of cyclical
uh a cyclical you know uh universe that
comes into and out of existence and
bounces
into and out of existence if you will so
there are many different possibilities
that could occur
and i think what's interesting is that
now especially with
sir roger penrose getting you know his
his attention do
do detention do attention not do
detention don't get me in trouble tony
uh but but the uh the actual
um conformal cyclic cosmology that he
prefers is sort of an endless cycle of
what he calls eons
that would uh that would go on to
eternity in both
space and time in a certain sense yeah
uh okay a couple more things here um
oh hey christians good to see you man
thanks for showing up um
let's see one more um let's see
should have been called the big
expansion not the big bang very true
um and andrew planet is commenting
perhaps we really need
to uh technology to see and understand
other dimensions
unlike animals that's a good comment
um let's see uh
frederick rose ides eyes and our other
senses detect different types of the
electromagnetic spectrum that's
well i don't know about other senses
only our eyes detect the e
m spectrum i guess unless heat well no i
guess your fingers
detect infrared pretty well don't they i
was like yeah
um okay so i guess that's true
hans just kicked in uh 20 bucks well i
don't know what's dkk what is that is
that north korean
yuan or i think hans is from denmark i
think i'm not sure okay
so denmark i think yes thank you thank
you by the way hans
he always supports and he's always
really generous with that so thank you
man it's
it means it means so we think it could
be like it could be a couple pennies i
don't know
yeah so so john suffel is
in the beginning was nothing and then it
went splat
and the biggest mystery is why it
freaking bothered in the first place
very good yes and hans is asking the
eternal question
when do when did the u.s go back to
normal time that's a great question i
think this weekend we have a lot of
things going on
we have unless you're in arizona unless
you're in arizona right you know
that's right and there's another state
too i forget that doesn't bother with it
but um
yes this weekend we have halloween we
have a full moon
and we fall back on our time so you can
be sure the united states may not be
around on monday it may not survive
that's tuesday catastrophe all of which
and then we get to worry about an
election in two days so yes the world is
in fact
the universe the universe is all screwed
up yes
okay so um all right it looks like
that's most of our comments that i have
a couple here let me just see
starting point uh could this mean
there's a cosmic starting point
potentially a white hole
yeah i actually talked today with uh
with an astronomer named uh
paul sutter who's written a book how to
die in space he runs a
a competitor channel to my channel into
into tony's channel named uh ask a
spaceman he's a phenomenal i don't
compete
you guys win you guys yeah that's what
you say when you don't have to compete
tony
no i don't i don't want to compete i see
chris chris is here from launch pad
astronomy yes he also doesn't
he's at that exalted michael jordan
level oh yeah
yeah i want to say that we're going to
have a series
or actually not a series i'm going to be
doing a bunch more live streams
so uh part of the uh awesome
uh you know benefit of having a youtube
channel on a podcast but also being
active in science research
is that i'm getting to talk to these
people like
sean carroll like uh max teg marks and
and so forth eric weinstein's what we
want to do
is leverage you know all the cool kids
yeah definitely well i'm getting them
all together
on november 10th in the at 9 00 pm
eastern time we are going to do
another live virtual stargazing
this time with adam reece nobel prize
winner adam reese
and with wendy friedman who's one of the
most brilliant
scientists in the world professor sarah
seeger of
mit professor jenna levin who's coming
out talk to her in a couple of hangouts
sarah's awesome
yeah sarah is amazing and jenna levin
has a new book coming
out on uh november 10th so i'm going to
do two live streams with jen 11.
uh you got to tune in for that she's
she's just blowing up she's one of the
coolest people in the world
uh she was on the tim ferriss podcast
over the summer
she's she's having a movie made about
one of her books uh by the moth
um and so we're gonna do live streaming
like we did over the summer with wyoming
uh stargazing association
with a 20 inch half meter diameter
telescope looking at the hubble space
telescope's greatest hits because as
tony knows it's the 30th anniversary of
hubble
i just wrote an essay on my youtube
channel called the greatest debate
but not about the biden uh trump debate
but about the great debate between
curtis
and shapley that hoped to decide the
origin
and the size of the universe and ended
up doing neither for several years
until like hanging chads in florida it
was eventually decided by edwin hubble
whose telescope has its name namesake
telescope has its anniversary
and the last thing we're hoping to
observe is a passage by the
international space station
because you may know it's also the 20th
anniversary of the launch of the
international space station
so we are doing a lot of
deep astronomical observations live live
astronomy and deep astronomy
on the uh dr brian keating youtube
channel so look for that with
uh authors nobel prize winners pundits
my friend david spurgle
and uh that'll be live looking at some
of the hubble telescope's greatest hits
and maybe just maybe
uh i'm gonna try to arrange a flyby by
the iss
uh captained by one of my former guests
uh you're gonna arrange a flyby
i am i am i'm actually going to do that
it's going to be lit up deep astronomy
lives here i like that
so thank you all so much please do
subscribe to my channel i'm trying to
grow
like my friend chris my friend tony you
guys are really inspirations to me and
i've benefited so much from your
generosity and from your graciousness
the two of you guys
really always help my channel so much uh
tony i wanna thank you so much sean
carroll i wanna thank him as well for
his time
look forward to i've got uh three more
nobel prize winners coming up
live in the next few weeks so please
stay tuned
yeah that and uh the uh link to the
discussion that uh brian had with uh
sean is in the description box of this
hangout and uh also subscribe to his
channel and do all those fun things
uh because it is really good content and
i highly i
i i wish i knew the people he knew i do
because brian the reason
i get to see and sort of live
vicariously through you and uh
and talk about and get access to these
people through you so it's really great
um thank you for taking time out uh for
being with us
um and i'm gonna go ahead and i guess
i'll stop the stream here
i don't know i don't know if i'm going
to be streaming tonight on clear skies
network or not i'm not prepared
uh usually i stream at nine o'clock on
thursday evenings eastern time
um i may or may not get my stuff
together in time if i am i will see you
there on clear skies network on twitch
otherwise i will be back uh with on look
for a space junk podcast episode we have
new stuff coming out from opt which um
you guys will want to learn about
and i'm actually going to start making
some podcast
changes here on deep astronomy as well
so i look for all of these things and
don't forget
to shave you're going to shake i like
i'm not going to shave
no but this is it this is my beard
that's the best i can do
alexa order razor blades for tony order
razor blades
say alexa play space fan news
razer blade refills
[Laughter]
gonna order me some area all right guys
thank you all on behalf of brian keating
my name is tony darnell thank you all so
much for watching
and as always keep looking up
you